foreign
hacked in 2011 to the 77 million
PlayStation accounts were indeed hacked
according to Sony if a huge cooperation
like Sony could not protect itself from
cyber threats you can assume that the
chances of any organization being 100
safe are pretty slim cyber security is a
booming industry and will be for the
foreseeable future considering most of
the it business has moved on to the
cloud according to recent Trend studies
the cyber security domain is set to
Skyrocket to nearly 200 billion dollars
by 2027. so what are you waiting for
stay tuned to this video on becoming a
cyber security expert in 2023 and jump
start your career in today's video we
will cover the basic responsibilities of
a cyber security expert and the
different types of cyber security
domains we go through the required
skills for being a cyber security expert
and a roadmap on how to become one
finally we cover the best cyber security
certifications to help you secure your
first job in this lucrative domain
followed by the different rules you can
aim for in this industry before we move
forward ensure your subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to stay
updated with the latest trends and
informative videos and for all the
budding cyber Security Professionals
here is a small question to test your
knowledge if a user finds a Facebook
Loan website that hackers set up to
steal passwords what attack can this be
classified as is it efficient is it B
SQL injection is it three adidos attack
or fourth crypto Jack let us know your
answer in the comments below and let's
start by learning about what a cyber
security expert does a cyber security
expert specializes in preventing
unwanted access to or theft of computer
systems and data more people and
organizations rely on the internet and
computers to conduct the day-to-day
activities in today's digital
environment because of this increased
Reliance on technology it has become a
major Target for criminals looking to
get access to confidential data or wreak
havoc on networks as a result there is
an increasing demand for qualified cyber
security Specialists who can assist in
mitigating these dangers experts in
cyber security typically have a computer
science or engineering backgrounds and
use their Computing systems expertise to
create sufficient Security Solutions and
use their Computing systems expertise to
create efficient Security Solutions
cyber Security Professionals need to be
technically proficient but they also
need to be able to think tactically and
keep up with the latest emerging
advancements in danger cyber Security
Professionals have the necessary skills
and expertise to identify suspicious
signals before the poser is they can
also keep track of the most recent
dangers and neutralize them before they
hurt the business with that being said
the key responsibilities include but are
definitely not limited to Gathering data
on current security measures for threat
assessment and keeping regular records
of the status of systems regularly
checking for assaults and if any are
detected implementing the necessary
preventive measures performing
vulnerability scanning to identify weak
spots and collaborating with a cyber
security team to update security
protocols as needed considering Security
First while setting up firewall software
Network firewall programs data servers
and Antivirus systems providing
credentials for unauthorized users
presenting tasks linked to access and
looking for changes to non-listered
information helping lead staff members
receive trainings on phishing and other
common threats with so many duties on
the board it's bound to expect multiple
categories in this domain so let's take
a look at the different types of cyber
security number one we have network
security this branch of network
engineering as opposed to focus on
individual databases or devices protects
against breaches for a network of
interconnected devices Network Security
Experts use firewalls physical
protective hardware and security
awareness to prevent breaches and retain
lost data email and user security may
also be a focus of network security the
professionals may lead organizational
initiatives to enforce tougher password
policies or to restrict web browsing to
reputable websites only the
professionals or have a more focused
area of work than cyber security
Personnel cyber security protects
attacks from attacks on individuals
networks hardware and software in
contrast network security focuses on
weak links between a network of
interconnected devices only
at number two we have information
security cyber security and information
security overlap to some extent but
cyber security is just a sub category of
the latter information security includes
digital and physical data across all
media whereas cyber security focuses
solely on securing digital assets
specialists in information security and
cyber security both Safeguard sensitive
data information but information
security considers factors like the
accessibility and confidentiality of
data to prevent access by cyber
criminals the number three is
infrastructure secured this domain can
concentrate on using vaults security
systems and generators to protect
sensitive valuables infrastructure
security the digital fear refers to
building and maintaining systems
protected from breaches Professionals in
this field different critical
applications and data while building
infrastructure to protect these devices
the experts create and Implement
efficient databases at the app level to
block access by malicious Parties by
creating systems for encryptions and
backups the professional secure data
against the hackers the skill set needed
to become a cyber security expert can be
query from domain to domain but the
major chunk of skills remain the same so
let's go through some of these skills in
our next section the top of our list is
being technically Adept cyber Security
Professionals must have a solid grasp of
computer networking and how they operate
they should also be aware of typical
security flaws and how to mitigate them
cyber Security Professionals must
recognize how hackers operate and think
and function to defend systems from
assault this enables them to predict
assaults and put effective
countermeasures in place number three is
having a methodical approach type
security work frequently demands a high
level of precision and a meticulous
attention to detail paying this
attention to nuances to find evidence
that could result in a successful attack
is very crucial to cyber security cyber
security issues are usually complex and
multifaceted as a result Specialists
must be able to spot issues and develop
Innovative solution using their problem
solving skills cyber Security
Professionals must be able to describe
technicalities to non-technical
colleagues and consumers fully you must
also be able to collaborate with others
on their team effectively so let's say
you have mastered the skills needed to
become a cyber security expert what
about the next steps our next section
will cover a roadmap that will provide
the exact sequence of steps needed to
become a cyber security expert in 2023
at number one we have basic computer
skills usually meaning the relevant
computer skills and systems knowledge
that is necessary to work your way
around hundreds of platforms while a
computer science degree is highly
preferable and helpful when starting in
this domain people from non-technical
backgrounds can also work in cyber
security if they train themselves in
basic Computing skills number two is
networking skills networking skills are
absolutely essential since a lot of the
work will revolve around wireless access
and network security protocols with
everything going Wireless networking
skills and particularly Wireless
networking should be the next step in
your journey after polishing your
networking skills the third obstacle
should be getting your knowledge of
Linux operating systems to at least
above average standards more scanning
tools and exploit Frameworks done
exclusively on Linux based distributions
like Kali Linux and parrot security
making it an absolute must before moving
forward basic scripting skills should be
the next step since developing and
combating exploits will require some
programming skills while not mandatory
these scripting skills will help you
modify exploits that can later be used
to secure infrastructure the next step
is the pH certification by TCM or the
Cyber Mentor this course will teach the
Practical aspects of ethical hacking
this course covers tools and Concepts to
help you succeed as an ethical hacker or
a cyber security analyst the training is
quite Hands-On and will cover a wide
range of fundamental subjects websites
like hack the box and try hack me are
virtual Labs that function as targets
for ethical hackers practicing their
craft as a cyber security professional
practicing on these rooms can help you
stay updated with the latest and most
complex tools available to penetration
testers today next is the ejpd
certification or the e-learn security
Junior penetration tester this
certification is a Hands-On course in
penetration testing and information
security fundamentals passing the exam
proves to businesses that you a cyber
security specialist is now ready for a
successful new job the last step is
getting an oscp or a pnpt certification
regarding a professional certification
that can help you grow further in the
domain you have these two options the
oscp online course can be completed at
your speed and schedule it covers
penetration testing tools and
methodologies through Hands-On practice
the program teaches the skills and
mindset needed to be a successful
vulnerability researcher and a cyber
security analyst the pnpd exam or the
Practical Network penetration tester
certification is a one-of-a-kind
vulnerability scanning certification
exam that evaluates a student's capacity
to perform a networking penetration test
at a professional level now that you
know the roadmap that needs to be
followed to become a cyber security
expert let's look into some of the best
certifications available on the market
today at number one we are going to have
the cissp certification it is based on a
common body of knowledge that covers a
broad range of topics including network
security cryptography and access control
to be eligible for the cisp though
candidates must have at least five years
of real life work experience in at least
two or more of the eight cisp domains at
number two we have the CES certification
or the certified ethical hacker the
certification validates the candidate's
ability to identify assess and mitigate
risks in an organization system to earn
the CH certification candidates must
pass an exam that covers topic such as
Network scanning enumeration social
engineering and SQL injection number
three we have the ccsp the certified
Cloud security professional credential
is a globally recognized certification
demonstrating a deep understanding of
cloud security architecture design
operations and services the ccsp
validates an individual ability to
secure cloud data along with its
applications and manage workloads
effectively
the food certification we have for you
is the cisa this exam tests the
candidate knowledge of information
system auditing control and security
candidates who passed the exam must
maintain the certification through
continued education and professional
development the CIS certification is
widely recognized as a benchmark of
excellence in information security as
you've already discussed there are many
facets to cyber security needless to say
there are a variety of rows to choose
from in this domain so let's go through
some of the most popular roles in the
cyber security division today at number
one we have the application security
engineer application Security Experts
can build deploy and manage computer
software and applications in various
sectors they work almost entirely in an
office setting with most of their time
spent writing and debugging software
fluency in several programming languages
like C C sharp Java Python and
JavaScript is necessary at number two we
have the security engineer they are
responsible for Designing and
implementing strategies that ensure the
security of an organization's products
and systems they must be able to examine
an organization's procedures and predict
future difficulties as a result they
must be skilled at incident response and
have solid computer forensics knowledge
number three is the network security
engineer network security Engineers are
critical in deploying setting and
managing Network and security hardware
and software examples being some
firewalls routers or network management
tools along with vpns they are also
responsible for undertaking network
security assessments and may be asked to
assist in the network infrastructure
design information security analysts are
in charge of investigating the security
issues and providing fixes the
responsibilities include researching the
sector identifying potential issues
implementing ways to secure the firm the
role needs a diverse set of abilities it
requires professionals to collaborate
with diverse people including analysts
inside and outside the business and
Senior Personnel I.T Security
Professionals examine an organization
security strategy and previous breaches
to determine how attacks happen and what
can be done to prevent them because it
and cyber security are such vast areas
firms typically employ many a security
specialist each specializing in a
distinct area for example one may Focus
solely on online applications while
another is responsible for the
organization's networks so that wraps up
our video on how to become a cyber
security expert in 2023. I hope a lesson
has cleared your doubts and about how to
start your career in this domain if you
have any doubts or queries feel free to
let us know in the comment section and
we will get your answers as soon as
possible if you have any doubts or
queries feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and you will get
your answers as soon as possible
subscribe to our channel for more
informative videos like this and thank
you for watching
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here